- [Announcer] It's been win,
win, win on Supermarket Sweep.
- Supermarket Sweep
was an iconic game show
in the ‘90s and early 2000s.
- [Announcer] And here is
our host David Ruprecht.
- Howdy, oh thank you.
But what most people didn't
know: all the meat was fake
and all the other food had gone bad.
Are you ready to play the game?
- [Announcer] Welcome
to Supermarket Sweep.
(upbeat music)
- Go Vicky!
We shot for about five
months, six months every year
and, uh, they used the same
food over and over again.
So by about the third month,
the hot dogs had sort of started
to ferment in the package
and the package swelled up.
And, a lot of the food,
having been thrown in and
out of carts for three,
four months, had gotten pretty beaten up.
And one of the things people always ask me
is: do they get to keep the food?
And, uh, no, and if they didn't win because
there were three teams,
they got their sweatshirts.
Unfortunately the winning team did not get
their sweatshirts, interestingly enough.
They got $5,000 but they
didn't get their sweatshirts.
(jazz music)
I shouldn't be telling you
this, it's a trade secret.
Very few people know
this and very few people
used this strategy,
but those who did, won.
Instead of five hams and five turkeys
that load up your cart, you come over here
and you get five of these hair
colorings and then you get,
well we won't mess with maxi pads.
You get five of all these
expensive health and beauty
products, with one cart
you can beat everybody.
Don't tell anybody, it's
just between you and me.
- I got it, I won, yeah!
- What a fantasy to be able to run around,
grab your favorite foods,
as much of it as you want
and not have to pay for it.
This is David Ruprecht saying,
“Next time you're at the checkout stand
and you hear the beep,
(beeping)
think of all the fun you could have on…”
- [All] Supermarket Sweep.
(upbeat music)
(alarms beeping)